what's going on God
my name is David Talmadge and welcome
back to the channel today we're taking a
look at the small but mighty Samsung
Galaxy buds we're gonna take an in-depth
look to see if they're really worth the
$250 they retail for today now I have to
apologize to you guys today because I am
a little bit sick so I'm drinking some
tea along this process however I haven't
missed an upload since I've started this
channel and I'm doing my best to make
sure I don't miss a Monday if you
haven't subscribed already
make sure you smash that subscribe
button 20-19 style and join me every
single Monday for brand-new tech and
econ related videos so let's talk about
some basics about the Samsung Galaxy
buds first of all it comes in three
different colors you can get them as
black white and apparently yellow
however on the Samsung website right now
in Australia at least you can't get them
in yellow and I haven't seen them in
yellow anywhere some quick stats that
might interest you is the fact that
these bluetooth headphones come with
bluetooth version 5 and also Android 5.0
unlike the icon X which was the previous
generation of Samsung bugs these are
completely compatible with any Android
or iOS o device however a little bit
later down this track in this video
you're going to find out why it's best
to stick with a Samsung device if you're
using a Samsung buds straight out the
box when you open them up they're going
to pair immediately to your Samsung
device if you have the app if you don't
have the app you're going to have to
download it however if you are on ISO
devices or any Apple device the app
actually isn't available to you and
you're just gonna have to pair it like a
normal bluetooth headphone one thing I
found interesting and actually had to
Google quite a bit to find out when I
first got my Samsung buds was how long
the charge time was from the case itself
so the galaxy buds themselves actually
hold about 6 hours of charge usually
playing any music or five hours talking
on the phone however if you do keep them
in the case they provide an additional
seven hours of charge which gives you a
total of about 13 hours maximum runtime
a second feature that I actually had no
idea about is the fact that they're
actually water resistant they have an IP
x2 rating which again I had to go up in
Google and find out what that actually
means and the definition by px2
is the fact that they're water-resistant
for anything hitting them at
fifteen degree angle now I don't know
how useful that is to you guys or how
useful that is going be to me but I'm
pretty much treating these headphones as
not really water-resistant
you shouldn't go swimming with them you
shouldn't go running in the rain with
them they're probably good enough to
withstand the gym sweat and you're gonna
get of everyday use I personally didn't
do a lot of research before I purchased
the Samsung Galaxy buds I didn't even
look at any youtube reviews so I wasn't
really too informed of what the specs
and features were when I got mine
originally I thought yes they have a
wireless charging what a great feature
and then I thought I wonder if it
charges my Samsung against a well
unfortunately if you've already looked
at a bunch reviews you know it doesn't
charge with anything but the Samsung S
10 which is really unfortunate because I
think wireless charging is basically
just a software update that samsa can do
it any time but hey I guess they really
got to keep their flagship models in
check and make sure you guys upgrade to
latest and greatest and make sure I
eventually upgrade to the S 10 as well
so when you look at the actual Samsung
bud earpieces you're gonna notice two
little gold specks on the inside and one
little black censor the black sensor
actually lets the earbuds know when
they're in your ear and when you place
them in they're going to make a little
tone and they also know when you pull
them out of your ear so they can go to
sleep and save battery straight away I
guess the main thing with any wireless
headphone and any headphone in general
is how good is the sound quality now I'm
gonna be a hundred percent honest with
you guys and it is good but it isn't
fantastic honestly the fact that these
little headphones do produce a sound
they do is amazing but they are missing
a little bit of bass I'm used to putting
on headphones like the Beats Studio
threes which have a ton of bass but
again they're huge over the ear
headphones which obviously can produce
that quality of sound these little guys
I've used for two weeks in the gym every
single day and not a single time have
they fallen out of my ears have they
been a problem they were a little bit
uncomfortable at the start but I think
that was just really a getting used to
it period and now they're completely
fine they sit in my ears completely
perfectly they never fall out and
they've lasted two weeks on a single
charge so that alone is incredible I
haven't had to go and plug them into the
charger
just popping my gym bag forgotten about
them and then when I'm done my workout
back into the charging case they go and
they charge ready for the next day
something that has annoyed me is the
fact that the headphones are adjusted by
tapping which I guess most headphones
are nowadays but the fact that these
headphones are so light and sit in your
ear
they almost kind of feel hollow when you
tap on them and the reverberation just
go straight into year so I actually have
to mentally think about it when I go to
tap and make sure that tap very lightly
so that ricochet doesn't go straight
into my head especially at like 5a in
the morning when you really don't want
to be hearing any extra noise continuing
here with the sound aspect of the
headphones the call quality on these
things is not amazing now I did watch a
video that the day that Samsung released
these headphones and they're talking
about how good the call quality was and
the dual microphone inside the
headphones that picks up internal and
external audio so when it's too loud
outside it picks up the sound of your
voice from the inside of your head
versus the outside but honestly the call
quality when you're talking on these
headphones is shockingly bad every
single time I'm talking on the phone to
somebody with these headphones plugged
in they're always asking me what did you
say can you turn up your volume can you
talk louder and it's an issue every
single time so usually you just cut them
out and you talk normally on your phone
now if you are an Apple user or an
iPhone user potentially any tablet out
there if it isn't a Samsung device or an
Android device you're not going to be
able to get the app now the app might
not seem like a big deal to some people
but it does come with some really cool
features for instance the app allows you
to change some of the gesture controls
on the headphones you can tap and hold
to activate Google you can tap and hold
to activate bigsby or cortana or
whatever you use except you can't do
that with siri because obviously you
can't get the app also a great feature
of the app is it has an inbuilt EQ which
lets you adjust the dynamic settings at
the headphones and get a little bit more
bass or a little bit more rich tones
depending how you like your sound I
found this a really helpful and really
effective feature inside the app which
actually does change the style and the
setting of
sounds quite dramatically I left mine
just on dynamic because I found that was
the best for me personally now another
little nifty and creative thing inside
the app is the fact that you can click
find my earbuds so if you ever go and
lose them or you drop them somewhere in
the gym on the floor in the couch
wherever you can just tap that button
and it's gonna start playing a super
high pitch tone out of the headphones
make sure they're not in your ears when
you test this feature out because it is
quite loud and I think it's about a
hundred decibels which you're going to
be able to hear if you're just looking
around for these headphones so props the
Samsung for throwing that feature in and
making sure we don't all lose these tiny
little headphones and that's all I have
for you guys today on the samsung galaxy
buds if I've missed anything let me know
in the comments down below a little bit
of an apology again for being sick but
as always make sure you smash that
subscribe button
20-19 style and I'll see you next Monday
you